there are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time so we gathered
some of the most hyped products from
august to test for ourselves
these chameleon flakes from kyma
cosmetics have been everywhere lately
they're definitely a unique product
because they're like little shavings of
pigment that shift color i wanted to try
these mixed with the glistening pigment
mix which is how i saw it being used all
over tik tok but i could not get this to
look good no matter what i did adding
more of the mix using less mixing it for
longer it honestly doesn't look that bad
on camera but nothing was making it look
like what i saw in so many videos i
finally decided to use it how it's
recommended on the product page just
apply a thin layer of glitter adhesive
and tap the flakes on and it works
amazingly these look so beautiful on the
eyes they really do but they come with a
bit of a learning curve
i am so into no makeup makeup right now
and i had to try out l'oreal's new
tinted serum with hyaluronic acid i'm
usually very skeptical of products that
combine skincare and makeup but i'm a
huge fan of this the coverage is light
but does a great job of evening the skin
out and giving a very glowy hydrated
finish and it claims to smooth your skin
over time i don't know how true that is
but if you're looking for a great skin
tint at the drugstore this is one of the
best i've ever tried
coley cosmetics is a new brand for me
these eyeshadow bases were all over
social media and i was very intrigued
because i've never used a colored base
before so to see what the difference was
i applied the base to just one eye and
then applied shadow to both eyes this
shadow is super pigmented on its own but
i could immediately see the difference
in the eye with the base versus without
the color was more pigmented vibrant it
even felt more neon to me and i didn't
use that much so i was super impressed
with this even the inner corner on the
eye with the base was brighter they sell
every color you'll ever need and you get
so much product for fourteen dollars
next i tried these little cotton swab
lipsticks from fomo me you basically
snap its neck and lipstick inside the
stick drains to the bottom end and then
you apply
this
worked i mean i can't say that it didn't
work the actual lipstick itself feels
like a very thin liquid once it dries it
really doesn't budge and it lasted on me
all day the color was definitely there
but the stain looked patchy because i
had some dry patches on my lips i don't
really see the point in a product like
this maybe if you're always on the go or
something or if applying regular
lipstick has just gotten too boring for
you but this seems like a lot of waste
for just an okay lip stain it was fun to
snap them open though and finally we
have an interesting product from pat
mcgrath the intensifies artistry wand i
was confused as to what this was at
first because it just looks like a fancy
32 chapstick but it's essentially a
mixing liquid in a convenient pen form
that intensifies eyeshadows so i applied
it to just one eye to see what the
difference would be to make things even
more difficult i used apache eyeshadow
from elf and also one of my dustiest
crustiest shimmers this shimmer is
literally four years old and pretty
dried out but i have to say that this
stuff did make these shadows look more
vibrant and surprisingly easy to blend
without getting patchy look at how
different these eyes look it mainly
seems like one of those products that's
made for a makeup artist kit and not an
everyday consumer
[Music]